qu'est ce qui s'est passé avec mathieu
au long du mois mort de l'écolier
j'étais en train de me faire coiffer et
monsieur à coke et est en train de se
faire coiffer tout ça est monsieur
études et grossièretés non je suis battu
deux mois de débats devant toi j'aime
pas ça du tout notre possible mais pas
toi je m'adresser aux techniciens
[Applaudissements]
ouais david tu me le sort à lui
maintenant de le sortir un avis très
vite c'est là en tant qu'artiste elle
parle et c'est ça voilà qu'on se connaît
très très bien démarré
je me rappellerai toujours et bah je te
jure c'est un des plus beaux moments de
ma vie je n'arrive pas à retrouver la
vidéo raconte à chaque fois vous un jour
on n'est qu'un copain parce qu'elle a
passé des vacances
elle a passé trois jours de vacances et
moi j'étais avec un copain on était haut
voilà en voiture et un moment on sait
pas pourquoi on entend derrière on
attend jeu elle commence à crier de ou
sur la voiture a sauté
qu'est ce qui t'a pris ce jour naïma bas
j'étais motivé
[Rires]